من نابلس ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره ليث
جعار ليث ماذا تكشف مع ساعات الصباح هذه
من مما حصل خلال اقتحامات قواه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
للضفه نعم العمليه العسكريه والاقتحامات
لا تزال مستمره وباتت شبه يوميه في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله حيث خلال الساعه الليل
اقتحم الاحتلال بلده عريف في مدينه نابلس
تحديدا منزل الاسير
باسل باسل شحاده والذي يتهمه الاحتلال
بانه احد منفذي عمليه عيليه قبل حوالي
اكثر من سته اشهر في جنوب مدينه نابلس حيث
قتل في هذه العمليه سته او اربعه مستوطنين
فيما اصيب اربعه اخرين في هذه العمليه
قوات الاحتلال هدمت المنزل بعد اقتحامه
واخلاء من ساكنيه بعد ذلك قامت ب البدء
باعمال التحفير في داخل المنزل تمهيدا
لتفخيخ وتفجيره في ساعات الفجر الاولى
انسحبت قوات الاحتلال بعد ذلك من البلده
فيما اقتحمت ايضا في مدينه نابلس تحديدا
بلده عورت الى الجنوب من مدينه من المدينه
حيث حاصر الاحتلال البلده
واقام بادخال حافلات المستوطنين نحو البؤر
او المناطق الدينيه التي يدعيها الاحتلال
انها تعود للانبياء
وانها مقامات دينيه مقدسه لهم قام
الاحتلال باقتحامها وا وسط تجديد على خروج
الفلسطينيين ايضا في مدينه نابلس خلال
ساعات الفجر اقتحم الاحتلال مخيم العين
وقام باقتحام احد المنازل فيما قام بتخريب
وا عبث في محتويات احد المنازل واعتقال
مواطن وهو اسير محرر اعتقل عده مرات سابقه
لدى قوات الاحتلال خلال ساعات الامس كان
هناك استهداف واستشهاد لفلسطيني في مدينه
طولكرم تحديدا عند حاجز عناب الى الشرق من
المدينه حيث اطلق جنود الاحتلال النار
عليه بشكل مباشر بدعوه تنفيذه لعمليه
اطلاق نار عند هذا الحاجز دون ان يصيب او
يوقع ايه اصابات بحسب ادعاء وبيان
الاحتلال ايضا خلال ساعات الليل قام
الاحتلال باقتحام مدينه جنين وبعض القرى ك
بلده يعبد التي باتت تشهد بشكل يومي
اقتحامات متواصله واعتداءات واغلاق لكافه
المداخل لهذه البلده والتي تقع عند حاجز
دوتان جنوب غرب المدينه وحيث يقوم
الاحتلال او قام الاحتلال خلال ساعات
الليل باقتحام البلده واقت التحام بعض
المحال التجاريه الاعتداء على المواطنين
ضرب بعض هؤلاء المواطنين جرت مواجهات خلال
هذا الاقتحام الامر الذي ادى لاطلاق النار
بشكل مباشر صوب الفلسطينيين ما ادى لاصابه
احد الشبان برصاصه في منطقه الفخد تم نقله
الى مستشفى سليمان الحكومي في مدينه جنين
ما بعد ساعات منتصف الليل قام الاحتلال
باقتحام بلده برقين ال وا ايضا ايه
منطقه محيط مخيم جنين وقام باقتحام عدد من
المنازل نفذ حمله مداهمات واسعه وتفتيش
فيما اعتقل الاحتلال عددا من الفلسطينيين
قبل الانسحاب بشكل كامل من البلده ومحيط
المخيم قوات الاحتلال خلال الاشهر السابقه
عمدت بشكل يومي والتي بات بالفعل هو مشهد
يومي في الضفه الغربيه المحتله و من حيث
الاقتحامات والاعتداء اات من قبل
المستوطنين والتي تزايدت ما بعد السابع من
اكتوبر حيث في كل يوم هناك اعتداءات على
المواطنين تحديدا في مناطق جنوب مدينه
نابلس مدينه سلفيت وقراها ايضا محيط مدينه
قلقيليه مدينه نابلس التي تشهد اغلاقات
واسعه والحواجز حاجز عورتا الى الشرق من
المدينه حاجز دير شرف الى الغرب وايضا
جنوب المدينه حاجز المربعه الذي يحاول
احتلال من خلاله عرقل حركه الفلسطينيين
ومنعهم من الدخول والخروج نحو المدينه
مدينه نابلس اصبحت عباره عن منطقه يعني
شبه معزوله نتيجه لاستمرار الحواجز
وا مكوث المواطنين لساعات طويله على الح
على الحواجز اثناء اثناء مرورهم او دخولهم
الى مدينه نابلس حيث يقوم الاحتلال بتفتيش
مركبات الفلسطينيين ناهيك عن ايضا
الاعتداءات المتواصله من قبل المستوطنين
على مناطق بورين وايضا عصيره القبليه
ومدمع والتي يعني باتت شبه يومي من
اعتداءات المستوطنين التي يعني الذين
يقومون بالنزول والهجوم على البلدات
والقرى الفلسطينيه في مناطق جنوب مدينه
نابلس والاعتداء على منازل وممتلكات
الفلسطينيين في بعض الاحيان يقومون بتكسير
المركبات وحرقها وخط شعارات عنصريه تدعو
لقتل وانهاء العرب شكرا جزيلا لك من نابلس
مراسل الجزيره ليث
جعار